political threat to the United States
just give me one more to answer
congressman Delaney can you repeat the
greatest geopolitical threat to the
United States right now congressman
Delaney
well the biggest geopolitical challenge
is China but okay geopolitical threat
yes remains nuclear weapons okay so
those are do you know that's a different
question
totally get it go ahead governor Inslee
the biggest threat to the security the
United States is Donald Trump
the greatest threat that we face is the
fact that we are at a greater risk of
nuclear war today than ever before in
history Congress Congress senators
rights economic threat China but our
major threat right now is what's going
on in the Mideast with Iran if we don't
try to keep it at work or Leonard
slimmer than what we've been going here
one or two our existential threat is
climate change we have to confront it
before it's too late senator one yeah
senator Booker nuclear proliferation and
climate change secretary Castro say
China and climate change
congressman Ryan China without a
question they're wiping us around the
world economically and mr. Mehra Russia
because they're trying to undermine our
democracy and they've been doing a
pretty damn good job of that and we need
to stop all right